playing fluffy from gamed well one of
the world's largest social games
communities the online game developer is
based in Berlin but it's not all fun and
games here it's hard work
graphic artists and mathematicians are
among the firm's highly qualified staff
almost 1/3 of the 205 employees come
from abroad and game dwell is looking to
hire 50 more skilled workers but if a
prospective employee comes from a nation
outside the EU the company's personnel
manager has his hands full for instance
it's hard when we want to recruit people
from Brazil and we had a really complex
case with the man from India who's
living in Finland it requires a mountain
of documentation and if someone hasn't
quite completed their studies or their
degree isn't recognized here it can be a
serious obstacle that's conscience I'm
block Ivan but the company needs foreign
workers firstly to find enough qualified
personnel and secondly because the firm
wants to attract gamers on the
international level Rahul Sharma began
working for gamed well last September
the head of personnel wants to know how
hard it was for him to apply and what he
thought of the recruitment process the
indian computer programmer is familiar
with the obstacles foreign applicants
come up against one of the biggest is
the german language thanks from elena
damn it how can I get a job if I don't
know the language Kevin yeah job ads are
all written in German and most of the
communication with companies is carried
out in German that makes it tough in the
beginning so most people say I'll go to
the US England or Australia instead
yet Germany should be pulling out the
welcome mat for immigrants the country
needs to attract skilled workers not
least due to demographic change labour
market researcher Herbert Brooker has
done the calculations if we take the
hypothetical situation that there's no
immigration than the workforce in
Germany would sink around 40% by the
year 2050 then we'd have just 27 million
workers instead of 45 million
that's why firms like gamed well want
the government to make immigration
easier Rahul Sharma favors a point
system like those used in typical
immigration countries here applicants
are rated according to criteria such as
job qualifications I'd say do something
like Australia or Canada do introduce a
point system so it's clear what you need
whether you're qualified enough and then
you can determine whether it's worth
investing your time applying or not yet
the immigration concept of Germany's
next government is still very vague
labour market expert Herbert Brooker
says current regulations like the one
requiring a certain income level should
be loosened and often it's a flight or
by crook it might be wise to continue
down the road we've started on and
liberalized things even more but I think
it's almost more important to advertise
this fact word hasn't yet gotten around
that Germany is open for immigration and
it's also a question of companies
conducting recruitment campaigns abroad
and this is just beginning when - 10
Bears come someone [ __ ]
gamed well is searching the globe for
qualified new employees but it would
make the personnel manager's job much
easier if he could hire foreign workers
without having to deal with so much red
tape